the average American spends 133 dollars
on Father's Day if you haven't bought a
gift yet you have 48 hours it's the
second year where I don't have a father
to buy a gift for I still reach for the
phone to call him I hear his echo when I
make an awful pun
he was very witty which is why his
favorite picture is with the comedian
Jack Benny the mirror now informs me
that I am at an age where I sometimes
look like him he was 92 and we completed
the cycle where we become fathers to our
fathers the man who carried me on his
shoulder with grit and grace was one day
the man I lifted to his hospital bed as
we get older we accumulate fathers and
their lessons my stepfather landed at
Normandy but never boasted about it he
could discuss an issue he knew
intimately with somebody who was certain
and loud and wrong and he'd never make
them feel smaller for their ignorance I
was often that person my father-in-law
turned 80 this year like the other two
an Eagle Scout self-made no pride but
quick to be proud of others he measures
twice and cuts once a father worthy of
his daughter this talk of gifts is not a
reminder to my children I don't deserve
a gift this year it's not that I'm not a
great father
just ask me I'll tell you I don't need a
gift because fatherhood is the gift you
never know something as deeply as when
you can see it through your love of your
children you've never believed in God as
much as when you have to explain to your
daughter why you believe in him without
taking the shortcut of saying that the
love you feel for her is proof that he
exists you've never heard John Prine
sing so sweetly as when he is seeing the
songs you sang as lullabies to the boy
who's sitting next to you at a concert
listening to them so this is a thank-you
note
I'm already grateful for being your son
your stepson your son-in-law and most of
all your dad I don't need a gift I'm
good I get mine every day beautifully
made you your dad to your father-in-law
your children yeah well and they did an
amazing job working on this Kira and
Cara and Clare and Joe so they all it
was really wonderful those words of John
Dickerson you know my I lost my dad when
I was a freshman college
Nora you're lucky you still have yours
and I always think people that have
their fathers are so lucky that they
have them in their lives yeah that was a
beautiful beautiful tribute all the way
around I'm lucky to work at a place that
lets me write it happy happy Father's
Day everybody fathers out there